this is one of our pride and joy it's
the outer 8,800 and it's commonly
referred to
although argue today it's the first
personal computer there were machines
that went before it it's unquestionable
but this one is considered the first for
a couple of reasons firstly the corns
disease it's holding it was lots of them
made they were kept form you could also
buy ready-made as well the most
important thing about it is the two
strands of computing that is sort of
created in that Bill Gates saw this
machine and thought this is fantastic we
can write software for this it's not
very usable as it is we're gonna write a
basic interpreter for it and Microsoft
was born on the other side of the fence
people like Steve Jobs well not people
like Steve Jobs Steve Jobs actually saw
this machine and and thought well ok
this is a start but it's not the
computer I want this I want a machine
that you can actually type on and comes
up on the screen that's where I see it
going and it spurred Steve Jobs and
Steve Wozniak into creating their
machines the Apple one and then the
Apple two and then everything else Apple
so it's a really really important
machine and a pivotal point in history
or from this one machine in 1975 it's an
American machine made by a company
called mitts and these guys were
originally sort of producing sort of
telemetry systems remote control systems
things like that but they were having a
very hard time and the the guy behind
MIT's sort of decided that you know he
had to go to the bank and say oh I'm
gonna need some more money otherwise
we're gonna hit the wall but I do have
an idea for a new product and it's a
computer that you can build and yeah the
you thought he might sell a few of them
but it ended up setting huge numbers of
them - it's a bunch of computer
enthusiasts basically and it actually
not so much computer enthused yes they
were at that time their electronics
enthusiasts they didn't know they were
computers into use yes until this thing
I hit so yeah and it's sort of a lot
more than you expected and you know
MIT's went on to produce sort of this
version and sort of later versions as
well but really did inspire you know
that generation into hacking these
things and making them do more than they
were capable of at the time and hence
the computer industry grew
it's original configuration it was
really really rudimentary you had no
keyboard yet no screen
you had these switches then the bottom
here so you had access to the data bus
there and you could toggle in data and
read it close to the address bus and you
could single step a load code into it
and the data is shown out on these lines
here so you programmed it in binary and
you've got your answers back in binary
you'd have the instruction set for the
the processor you could then look up the
opcodes they would have a binary
represent representation you toggle
those in steps in the X location put the
next up code Ian it's you know very very
rudimentary machine code programming and
as you've got to know this machine and
the the opcode set for that processor
you started to remember these things and
you remembered the kind of the pattern
more than the actual the the numbers but
you remember those powers you could
toggle in things reasonably quickly but
still hideously Sloane today sort of
comparisons so one of the first things
that people remember doing with it of
any great sort of sheikhs was toggling
in some code which is basically just a
lot of delay loops and guy called Steve
Dompierre took it to the homebrew club
and set it up on the on the table
started toggling in his code and
ultimately it's great everybody sort of
gathered around him said right I'm gonna
run the code and this sort of program
full of delay loops you know how your
cue function is food and you get the
buzzing noises when something's going to
ring you they used an FM radio at the
time the interference created by the
processor in the circuitry interfere
with the radio so the longer the delay
loop the lower the buzz was on the radio
code and the short that I loop the
higher the buzz was so yeah doing that
got it to play the fall on the hill the
old Beatles tune at the time
[Music]
when people work you know there is
fantastic you know we've got this
committee to do something and this will
one of the early stories that sort of
came about from the the outter but it's
a really intriguing machine because of
you know these stories that are
associated with the the people that were
using it and and the stories of the
homebrew club at that time which you
know created a whole group of people
that create machines that change their
lives
is the big reveal so this is the
internals of our serial number three and
it's quite drastically different it has
a simple circuit board inside just one
circuit board with all the components on
and it had this connector at the back
which allows you to increase it to a
massive 16 K of memory with that Ram
pack